Tik Tok live is a beast attention is the
number one asset is a beast howwi right
now if you went on Tik Tok live for 3
hours a day for three CU I'll go on Tik
Tok live a lot but I I you know I'll
spend a half hour the longer the better
because the way that algo is working and
the way I'm seeing it from my perch is
Tik Tok is really testing their live
product and they're helping more
exposure for the people that are
committing more to the platform so the
longer you're on it you're growing
unlike a platform like Instagram live
where you go on and you can see the
audience dip because all they're doing
is informing your entire audience and
then everyone comes and then a
percentage goes away what Tik tok's
doing is you go live and it's showing up
in the algorithms and people are
discovering you wow